pero el momento de hablar de la
información económica en france 24
operacional compañía en el estudio
daniel hablando me dan y vamos a hablar
como no del el vigésimo aniversario de
los ataques del 11 de septiembre cuáles
fueron las secuelas económicas de esos
atentados o la wan pues mire ni eeuu ni
el mundo son iguales desde ese 11 de
septiembre de 2001 al menos
económicamente hablando en ese entonces
quedó no solamente una desoladora estela
de muerte sino también efectos notorios
en la economía y en la infraestructura
obligando por ejemplo a que se
destinaran millonarios fondos públicos
para la reparación de víctimas
consultamos con juan carlos rivera
analista económico para que nos
expliquen mejor cuáles son esos efectos
que dejó este atentado a la economía
mundial la economía de los eeuu venía
decreciendo desde
1999 de 14.7 hasta 2001
que terminó con un crecimiento económico
del 0.99 es decir ni siquiera del 1% la
economía de los eeuu estaba en recesión
justo después de los atentados la
economía de los eeuu empezó a
recuperarse y se recuperó continuamente
durante unos dos o tres años posteriores
a los atentados
en europa no fue lo mismo en europa el
producto interno bruto de los países
amigos de los eeuu
francia italia alemania españa reino
unido
empezaron a descender no en grandes
proporciones pero si se presentaron de
crecimientos por los efectos que
causaron los ataques terroristas en los
eeuu si le parece juan ahora vamos a
hacer un repaso de las cifras el costo
de los daños está calculado en 60 mil
millones de dólares y sólo en el primer
mes después del ataque las pérdidas
sumaron 123 mil millones también hubo
ayudas económicas a las aerolíneas por
15 mil millones de dólares y el congreso
aprobó un paquete de emergencia por 40
mil millones danny para américa latina
estos ataques tuvieron consecuencias
económicos pues mira eeuu ha disfrutado
de una hegemonía global tanto política
como económica y eso hace que lo que
sucede allí directa o indirectamente
afecte a los países de la región en
especial algunos como méxico con el que
tiene una relación económica muy sin
embargo parece que este no fue el caso
según nos dijo nuestro analista juan
carlos olivera américa latina salió
avante después de estos atentados
terroristas toda vez que el producto
interno bruto de la mayoría de los
países siguió su comportamiento normal
las inflaciones no se dispararon y el
desempleo solamente se vio afectado de
una forma ínfima en las empresas
relacionadas con aerolíneas turismo y
hotelería
es importante mencionar que américa
latina' adquirió compromisos con el
gobierno de los eeuu para reforzar la
seguridad tanto en los aeropuertos como
en los aviones que viajarían con
destinos hacia los eeuu
entonces es importante mencionar
y dejar claro que américa latina no
sufrió grandes repercusiones económicas
después de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre seguimos con este tema cuál
ha sido el gasto de eeuu en fondos
públicos para reparar precisamente a las
víctimas
juani de un total de dos mil novecientos
setenta y siete personas murieron en los
ataques de aquel 11 de septiembre hace
20 años tanto al world trade center como
al pentágono y las reclamaciones
económicas al gobierno de eeuu fueron
millonarias pues se estima que hubo 66
mil 693 solicitudes de reparación por
parte de los familiares de las víctimas
pero sólo 41.000 154 casos fueron
resueltos a favor de los solicitantes en
términos económicos fueron en total 8
mil 950 millones de dólares en los
próximos meses estas familias de hecho
podrán estar más cerca de esclarecer la
verdad sobre lo sucedido aquel día el
pasado 3 de septiembre el presidente joe
biden firmó una orden ejecutiva que
instará a la desclasificación progresiva
de todos los documentos confidenciales
relacionados
ataque vamos con la cifra del dia
429 mil personas perdían su empleo
durante los tres primeros meses después
del atentado de ese 11 de septiembre en
eeuu guardia donde él hablando
muchísimas gracias gracias también
ustedes por estar con nosotros quédense
en la pantalla de france 24